these devices uh amplify
the human tendency to to
engage or indulge in excessive thinking
and problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking
focused thinking uh so
the what you are doing uh is
uh very very helpful because you are
basically uh
having a period of uh we could call it
decluttering your mind
you declutter your mind and this is
necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been
as cluttered as they are now
glutton means there's a continuous input
of
stuff that comes in through the devices
the messages come in facebook posts
tweets and continuously the devices
demand your attention
and say this is important and a lot of
it is not important
but as we all know
there's an addictive quality to it
well first off of course it's going to
help people but really you're describing
my own
personal journey almost to a t and
you're actually also describing why this
will be my fifth year doing this off the
grid
august situation because it was on the
first one
where i was sitting on a beach and david
kept saying to me for days why aren't
you reading a book
why aren't you just sitting and staring
at the ocean and i said that that's
actually what i need right now
and it was truly in that moment when the
thought popped into my mind
that i'm not an atheist and i would say
in the in the five years since then have
been the most sort of rewarding and
enriching
and full years that i've had on this
planet so i actually so i wonder could
to connect that to what i'm doing with
this month
um i i suppose someone like you kind of
kind of digs something like this the
idea that someone could put down the
devices
and i wonder what what do you think just
in general about a world
that is so obsessively connected to
other people's thoughts
all day long yes that's good so um
the over this um excessive
identification with thinking and
overthinking ex
excessive thinking had been there for a
long time long before we came up with
these
devices but these devices
amplify the human tendency to
to engage or indulge in excessive
thinking
and problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking
focused thinking uh so
the what you are doing is
very very helpful because you are
basically
having a period of uh we could call it
decluttering your mind
you declutter your mind and this is
necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been again as
cluttered as they are now
glad that means there's a continuous
input of
stuff that comes in through the devices
the messages come in
facebook posts tweets
and continuously the devices demand your
attention and say
this is important and a lot of it is not
important
but as we all know
there's an addictive quality to it it
draws
your attention to it and then every time
it draws your attention
you add to the clutter of your mind a
lot of not is not constructive
a lot of it is just random people often
see people
they get out their phones and they do
this
random scrolling i can see it's random
there's nothing specific
but they think they have to do it
because everybody else is doing it
around them
wherever you are these days people are
engaging with this
and they're continuously taking in
thoughts from
others and as we said before
some of these thoughts may be toxic and
they
may easily become lodged in your mind
uh so to declutter is extremely
important
and you can see if you even just
not using a device for a day
for many people is very very hard
and some think they can do it but they
can't so they are truly
addicted um
now when you when you when you declutter
your mind
first of all you put down your phone you
don't use it
not everybody can do it for whole months
like you of course
but i recommend to everybody to have
certain periods of time when they
do not engage so for example
in your bedroom might be a good place to
chart for not engaging with any device
certain periods of time when you go out
into nature
be there rather than carry that thing
and every time it makes a noise you
still look up and you still
even while you're surrounded by beauty
and aliveness
you're still engaging with this or
everything that you are looking at is an
opportunity
for an instagram post and you're just
looking
look up i'm here now me here
me there and then he sent it out
to so you never again
become completely trapped in in the mind
more than more than even with these
devices i'm very
concerned about youngsters these days
who grow up with them
the first perhaps is the first
generation i don't know the first iphone
was maybe 12
13 years ago something like that and
these
many youngsters uh for many youngsters
the virtual
reality is more important to them
than others and this is a very dangerous
development the they lose the ability to
relate
to other humans they spend several hours
per day
on devices whereas before they would go
out running around outside
playing their games uh creative
coming up with new games creative
activities relating to nature climbing
up trees
yes it's a little bit of risky you might
fall down but again our society is
obsessed with safety and security but
anyway let's not go there right now
so i'm very concerned
[Music]
if
it's not inconceivable that it could
have such a detrimental
effect on consciousness that within
two generations it could lead to
the breakdown of civilization because
humans would no longer be able to
creatively think focus on a specific
problem
for long enough to find a solution uh
connect
with the deeper intelligence that is
necessary to
to do anything creative in this world
could give attention to something for a
certain period of time
rather than have a short attention
periods periods you can't
focus on anything for very long how can
you solve a problem
if you can cannot look at it face it and
then
become to still for a moment activate
your deeper intelligence
and then see what the solution might be
so if
we lose the ability you know that
it's parents responsibility to limit
their children's time with these devices
and
i would suggest periodically take them
out into nature without
these things so that they don't lose
their ability
to connect with nature why it's so
important to connect with nature
to because they you find sanity there
that was my saving thing when i was a
child i would get on my bike i was very
unhappy in my home environment
this was very very dysfunctional
my parents couldn't help it they were
just in the grip of dysfunction
as and their parents had been in the
grip of dysfunction and so i would get
to my bike go out into nature
like a 15-minute bike ride not
magnificent fantastic nature just
normal fields groves of trees
and there i would suddenly get off my
bike and say ah
but i didn't have any devices to
distract me if there weren't any
i would actually be there and look
and i would often say to myself this
will always be here
i didn't know what that meant i i could
feel that nature was more important than
the man-made world the human-made world
the human-made world for me was a very
unhappy one
and the the natural world was where i
found
liberation whenever i went there uh
but if i had these phones i would have
carried that with me and probably
no longer be able to really relate to it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell